stop talking about the other players in
your game as competitors because
competitors are there to be beaten
and so you spend all your time trying to
beat your competitor in a game that has
that's stupid that that doesn't exist
you make up your own metrics in your own
time frames you can be a winner or loser
every day if you want
um um and start thinking of them as
rivals
um and some of those rivals are worthy
of comparison and a worthy rival
is another player in the game who does
some or many things better than you
they reveal to you your weaknesses and
now go
make yourself a better company um and as
soon as the pandemic hit
there was not a single company zero zero
companies on the planet earth
when the pandemic struck that was trying
to beat their competition zero
they were just trying to survive well
whether it's whether it's recessionary
times or a bull market
that should be your attitude always
survive stay in the game as long as
possible
and i thought that was so funny that we
had no problem taking our eyes off the
competition and focus on improving our
own systems
and figuring ways to stay in the game
that's called infinite mindset and it
happened
[Music]
immediately